il y a trois ans bernard tapie annoncé
être atteint d'un cancer dans une
interview exclusive menée par laurent
delahousse
quand on vous apprend que vous avez un
cancer
c'est comme si on était une batte de
baseball dans la tête hier soir sur
france 2 laurent delahousse recevait de
nouveau l'homme d'affaires pour prendre
de ses nouvelles
une interview poignante au cours de
laquelle il est revenu sur son combat
j'avais perdu 75% tout bitumées puis en
deux mois elle avait doublé avec des
buts assad
l'occasion aussi pour lui de parler de
son clan familial et plus
particulièrement de sa femme dominique
elle est là très partie brûlot à toute
sa famille un soutien de taille dans la
maladie d'ailleurs ce soir un de ses
quatre enfants est avec nous des fans
qui tout comme son père s'est lancé dans
la télé et qui a monté sa société de
production y est aujourd'hui directeur
des activités numériques du groupe la
provence et il est venu ce soir nous
parler de son père
moi je connais bien figurez-vous à
stéphane bancel a pas de mal à la jambe
pourquoi tu sais quand j'ai parlé aux
autorités françaises la première fois de
convaincre sa en avril et je demandais
du fric ils m'ont même pas répondu et
corte le trouver il existe que les
étapes dangereuses sont passés en
novembre et nous on n'y croit toujours
pas mais un art appuyé alors stéphane
quand vous le voyez comme ça ils
arrivent à ses derniers records à eux
c'est incroyable ça ne s'arrêtera pas à
tanis lève le matin il s'est dit ah bien
ils font à bloc toujours à fond à bloc
comment il va la gagner beaucoup
ouais mais il va que motul à vue hier il
est vachement ou qu'il a vachement de
franchise même quand sa maladie qui dit
quand ça va mieux il dit quand ça va
beaucoup moins bien ils essaient de
désacraliser le terme de cancer il
essaie de 2,2 de se servir de son
expérience pour que ceux qui ont un
cancer nous et plus la honte d'en parler
voilà c'est pas une maladie et nicolas
tout à l'heure pernikoff on en parlait
et c'est vrai que les gens c'est quand
ils apprennent que tu as un cancer ils
viennent un peu puis s'ils se mettent un
peu plus loin c'est pas quand c'est pas
contagieux un cancer c'est qu'il faut il
faut le banaliser il faut le
désacraliser voilà s'approcher encore
plus n'ont pas besoin vais toujours vous
avez toujours rêvé de ça ou ça ne va pas
hyundai et ça nous a pas rapprochés sont
allées encore encore victorieux les vous
engueuler encore encore heureux
je sais que vous fait mourir de rire les
avaler de ccc c'est incroyable sophie
aussi avec lui ils s'engueulent encore
avec vous mais mais mais pire on s'aime
pareil et puis c'est aussi pareil et
puis ça dure dix minutes après c'est
reparti il oublie évidemment c'est
reparti comme en 14
un sexe il y en a plein ici qu'ils le
connaissent qu'ils assurent son public
déjà tu le connais très bien gilles
voilà on
on a vécu beaucoup de choses avec lui
benjamin il était la dernière l'été
dernier livre ça marseille à marseille
marseille
voilà comment il faut c'est lui qui vous
l'a dit bah oui il vous a écouté à quoi
voulez vous la dire chacun votre tour
vous a provoqué vous a dit non non je
lis mon linge une merde ah ouais ça
ouais ça fait quelques années dans la
rue dit non mais là les et c'est un
cancer ah ouais ça c'est une grosse
perte
les autres à côté c'était rien alors on
la pudeur au fait que en temps en temps
on en parle on en parle quand c'est bien
on en parle comme c'est moins bien et
puis temps en temps on n'a pas envie
d'en parler essayer d'en parler le moins
possible afin de nous s'il n'y a pas de
tabou il n'y a pas de tabou mais ça ne
s'est pas le sujet principal de
discussion c'est au téléphone alors la
tumeur à bakambu
comme hier me casse pas les maths c'est
ça donc
et il avance ouais il avance il avait
fait ce qu'il a à faire on fait ce qu'on
a à faire et puis alors il a également
évoqué une anecdote troublante en 96 il
a joué dans un film de claude lelouch
vraie femme mode d'emploi dans ce film
son personnage est atteint d'un cancer
de l'estomac et c'est pas tout puisque
même le reste de son histoire possède de
nombreuses coïncidences avec sa
situation actuelle regarde je sors de
l'hôpital de nice on vient de m'annoncer
que j'ai un cancer de l'estomac elle et
en celui qu'on découvre dans ce film qui
est mon médecin dans le film regardez
dit dis je vais à nice je rentre dans
l'avion au premier rang bien pierre
arditi et j'attrape il dit comment vas
tu lui pierre tu te souviens ce que tu
me trouver comme maladie il ya 25 ans
mais biou et je dis aujourd'hui c'est
vrai on s'est attrapé parce que c'était
inimaginable c'est c'est incroyable
intérim soit il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
gens qui réagissent encore et c'est vrai
que c'est c'est formidable c'est cette
fois j'ai chez moi j'étais scotché wade
il je suis toujours extrêmement ému
quand
on parle de bernard tapie c'est vrai
pour tout ce qu'on a vécu est là j'ai
été cueillis bouleversé par l'interview
franchise une combativité aussi une
sagesse
un grand moment d'humanité de télévision
c'était c'était merveilleux et c'est un
message d'espoir pour tous les gens
malades
il transmet cet espoir battez vous et
c'est cette énergie que je retiens c'est
même leur entourage il faut pas qu'il
faut pas le considérer comme un malade
il faut pas le traiter comme un malade
il faut voilà il faut être naturel comme
je disais à la base un benjamin passé à
ses riches amis j'ai eu une attaque paul
je veux ta gueule et tu tant que tu te
retiens pas parce qu'il a un cancer
l'entourage est très important aussi je
vois certains c'est ça c'est hyper
important vous n'ayez pas changé de nom
je vois certains qui regardent leur père
leur mère ou leur faisant ou leurs
frères et soeurs parce qu'il a un cancer
avec la regarde différemment si tu leur
jette un regard différent eux mêmes vous
vont voir dans tout dans tes yeux
et là c'est terrible pour eux parce
qu'ils vont se considérer d'un coup
comme des malades willy colin non à un
moment donné ce que je disais à stéphane
c'est qu'il dit nous les cancéreux c'est
la première fois que j'entends ça c'est
à dire qu'ils arrivent à mascouche à
andré sacraliser la maladie et c'est
vrai que ce que disaient c'était fin du
grand prix jenson man il faut pas
l'oublier quand vous avez un cancer il
ya beaucoup de gens dont vous n'avez
qu'une nouvelle il ya beaucoup de gens
qui s'en vont comme si ça pouvait être
comme si on pourrait être contaminée
comme si ça pouvait être contagieux et
là un moment donné c'est toujours pareil
cet homme c'est incroyable il donne de
l'espoir même au bout de la maladie
mystère que là aujourd'hui il est en
train de donner de l'espoir à tous les
gens malades en disant un tout le monde
vous traite de la même manière dans les
hôpitaux c'est pas parce que je suis
bernard tapie que j'ai droit à un autre
et n'atteint donc ça c'est quand même
quelque chose d'important parce qu'on
t'a beaucoup sur la france en ce moment
le système de santé et égalitaire pour
tous le monde des plus pauvres aux plus
riches ça c'est le premier point est le
deuxième point c'est vraiment très
important nous les cancéreux c'est à
dire que nous les cancéreux il banalise
un peu le cancer et donne beaucoup
d'espoir au combien c'est un point sur
cette humeur bernard tapie c'est vrai
que c'était étonnant ça aussi ce moment
de l'interview regarde le traitement qui
est efficace ont fait leurs preuves
j'avais perdu 75 % de mes tumeur en deux
mois
elle avait doublé avec des bêtas salle
mais la vérité c'est que c'est un combat
intérieur entre qui et qui
des tumeurs et votre système immunitaire
comment ils fonctionnent à l'énergie
si l'énergie que vous avez est plus
forte que l'énergie de tumeurs elle
vient de taper la muse allait gagner et
pour avoir de l'énergie ya un moyen
c'est de faire de l'exercice
il continue à faire de l'exercice c'est
la croix parce qu'on a l'impression d'un
mois que c'est vraiment documenté ceni
je vais essayer mais aussi de connaître
ce que j'ai lu et essayait vraiment de
voir comment ce pôle combattre aussi
oui enfin je sais pas du tout dès qu'il
a deux heures où il est pas fatigué il
fait deux heures de sport ah ouais ouais
c'est sa façon de le combattre
et il a raison il entretient cette
humeur cesser ces cellules saines
enfin voila il les entretiens donc et
c'est celle ci qui vont combattre les
mâles et les mauvaises alors il s'est
bien sûr confié sur ses enfants eje sur
sur sa femme il a fait des confidences
touchante regarde une personne que vous
n'auriez pas pu emmener mais celle qu'on
voit jamais admis qu elle vous pas elle
veut pas elle veut pas elle est là
depuis toutes ces années elle ne veut
pas paraître elle aime pas mais allez
allez attention venir c'est pas lui fait
et moi nous chaque fois qu'il ya un
problème c'est dix mois qu'est ce que tu
penses tout ça
oui en général en plus même quand - jour
on s'est rencontrés on était chez vous
et puis on avait bien senti qu'à un
moment donné c'est elle qui venait voir
en disant maintenant faut arrêter quoi
faut rentrer c'est elle qui met les
limites ou est-ce que vous allez un
petit peu trop loin parfois ils sont
beaux tous les deux à huawei c'est un
couple incroyable
c'est incroyable ah ouais bah c'est ce
qu'ils ont tous connu à écoute ma
belle-mère
ça fait des années que je la connais
face et c'est un couple extraordinaire
et elle a une patience c'est franchement
c'est je pense que c'est vraiment 80% de
sa force et l c'est une ciné c'est une
force de la nature
il le dit d'ailleurs un il me dit
souvent oui non mais que lui le disent
c'est encore heureux mais moi qui en
plus j'ai toute légitimité c'est pas mal
voilà je trouve qu'elle est allée
extraordinaire avec lui mais vraiment
aller fabuleuse avec lui c'est quand
j'entends un épi et pis c'est vrai que c
est le métronome
c'est le métronome la raison le rang
quand il dit que de temps en temps elle
arrive et même encore aujourd'hui quand
il commence partir dans ces réunions à
machala rentrer à fait stop final tout
le monde dehors bon on le fait un peu
plus la sueur féminin mais ça veut dire
la même chose mais c'est ouais c'est une
femme extraordinaire passé c'est un
couple extraordinaire jradi en fait il
ne veut ni pitié ni qu'on le regarde
comme un pestiféré
j'ai l'impression que quand il est sur
les plateaux télé en fait à force de
nous mêmes à fos à force de le
verbaliser ça le galvanise et ce à
l'aide aussi à lutter contre la maladie
alors c'est pas une chimio c'est pas une
radiothérapie c'est pas un protocole
spécial mais je pense que aussi d'en
parler comme ça ça lui donne une sorte
de force et de combativité afghane n'a
rien de honteux en fait non il ce qu'il
est vraiment ses pouvoirs et des bisous
voilà kochi quand il va recevoir et
c'est pour ça qu'il a parlé de la lettre
à un moment donné à laurent de la hausse
un monsieur de 80 2 ans qui qui qui a un
cancer depuis quatre ans qui était en
train végéter dans le soulier et depuis
la dernière fois qu'il l'avait entendu
il lui a envoyé une photo de lui avec
une lettre très émouvante et une photo
où il disait où il posait avec un vélo
il est à cause de vous maintenant je me
suis remis à faire du vélo parce que
vous m'avez métro galvanisé et c'est que
ça qui lui fait mais continuer sur ce
plateau ça me fait du bien aussi ça
prouve qu'il est encore vivant qu'on l'a
quoi quand on les écoute qu'on lidl
n'ont vraiment pas il n'a pas besoin de
plateaux de télé pour être vivant
il n'y va jamais pour rien il y va parce
que là il y est allé pour parce que
voilà avec le comique dont on parle
beaucoup du comique du comique du
comines
on a un peu oublié les cancéreux ils
sont un petit peu mis vraiment à l'écart
et de côté et pour cause ils sont très
beaucoup plus fragile que nous tous de
par leur système immunitaire
donc voilà je pense qu'ils avaient
besoin aussi de redonner un petit coup
de boost à eux
voilà où on vous oublie pas je suis là
vous inquiétez pas on bosse toujours on
y va on avance et découragent d'égards
oui
kelly oui j'ai souvent vu que que chez
certains malades le mental était et
géraldine peut-être que ce ne sont pas
les plateaux mais ce sont sûrement aussi
beaucoup l'entourage et lui sa force de
base mentale parce qu'il parle d'énergie
dans son corps pour combattre ça mais
moi je pense que l'énergie c'est aussi
dans le mental et il a l'air vraiment
vraiment vraiment très fort et et c'est
juste magnifique de le voir aussi bien
accompagné je pense que c'est ça aussi
qui aident à lutter et du toujours dans
ma vie et c'est samedi au fond j'ai
adoré cette interview je les trouve
extrêmement touchant qu'il faut savoir
qu'à chaque fois que bernard tapie prend
la parole à la télévision c'est un
record d'audience est vrai il y avait
sept millions de français devant la télé
hier soir et je pense et des audiences
qui sont à la hauteur de l'amour que les
français ont pour lui ils ont ouvert
l'émission avec un petit micro-trottoir
tout le monde l'a d'or pour son côté
cash mais aussi pour la proche de la
maladie qui l'a on la dit très
transparents non vraiment j'ai déjà dit
moi je vais te dire que c'est stéphane
sais pas si tu l'as dit bernard mais moi
je le connais un peu mythique on sait
jamais vraiment vraiment rencontré ton
père est mon 9
on sait qu on s'est eu au téléphone et
on s'adore par téléphone il c'est bon je
t'aime beaucoup et qu'on est à l'époque
et quand j'ai eu des fois parfois j'ai
eu des petites galères en télé tout ça a
été un des seuls 1 rappelé je sais je
sais il m'a dit ton merde pas avec ses
coûts fais ton taf
et voilà t'emmerde pas et ça m'a
beaucoup touché j'ai trouvé vraiment
exceptionnel comme toi on aime les gens
vrais tu sais mais je les adore tu sais
que je suis non mais il aime les gens
vrais voilà c'est pour ça qu'il adore
laurent aussi de là c'est vrai c'est
vrai que ça qu'il a dormi cause parce
que c'est un mec très vrai après ces
recettes viennent voilà assez restreint
mais il y a des gens qui l'aiment
beaucoup toi ils t'ont fait partie bas
parce que tu as cette nature est ce
naturel qu'il aime beaucoup
voilà c'est ça et c'était ctc tiens
d'ailleurs franchement c'est un des
grands souvenirs de ma vie j'étais dans
la vie elle-même avec quoi et avec les
nems avec toi exactement
j'ai une question office comment vous
vivez stéphane les combats de voter ça
parce que là moi j'ai quand même flipper
tout le procès je vais vous dire je suis
un français comme un autre j'ai quand
même fait flipper pour votre père pascal
était dans un état un peu fragile
il y avait des médias la presse il n'a
pas été épargné dans sa vie comment vous
vivez ces moments là vous en tant que
fiston ses terres où vous arrivez à le
protéger vous arrivez le meilleur papa
ne va peut-être pas fait attention à toi
comment ça aussi je commence à les dire
n'y va pas il va y aller vous l'avez que
tu me laisses faire d'accord voilà tu le
laisse faire il a son petit truc lycées
y se gère très bien vous vous livrez
comment à ce moment là mais très bien
les regarder le paquebot du temps qui se
gère lui tout va bien stéphane je vais
parler en tant que pote moi je t'ai
jamais vu angoissé dans pour ton père
pour les amériques moyen voulais qu'ils
jamais vu ont chaque fois mais enfin si
je vois qu'on dirait que c'est ça fait
partie de la vie mais non c'est pas sa
vie nous on sait l'on connaît la vérité
donc oui on sait qu'un jour elle va
éclater voilà la preuve elle a éclaté
d'un seul procès au pénal
connu et reconnu innocent et la merde
ouais mais nous on n'était ni surpris ni
on le sait depuis le début et à un
moment donné tu sais que la justice va
être fait
donc voilà il n'y a pas de souci
là-dessus donc c'est vrai que parce que
sochaux est sûr toujours très
découlerait très attendu e par rapport à
ça ouais
et puis au pire un cia l'a pu tu va
rechercher un autre
ouais c'est ça ils vont pas de face à
l'envoi sans corsa ou plus du tout s'il
veut être là haut pour mais pour moi de
mai ouais c'est ça c'est vraiment c'est
assez une fixation
ouais j'ai vu par l'intrus mois de mai
on va voir un dernier extrait au moins
un bernard également révélé qu'il
n'avait pas pu n'ai pas voulu dévoiler
les bonnes actions qu'il a pu faire et
qui aurait pu lui donner une meilleure
image au regard des j'ai toujours
pratiqué la communication par les grands
médias que lorsque j'étais convaincu que
ce que je faisais était utile par contre
tout ce qui était éventuellement très
profitable à mon image et que j'avais
que ça
à faire savoir je le disais pas toi tu
es c'est pas bien sûr mais c'est vrai
que parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui
étaient contre bernard tapie ont acquis
c'est vrai qu'il en politique
hollande était la première fois qu il
avait été ministre de la miss avait été
une erreur et la deuxième fois c'était
une faute mais même même veine mais pas
tous bien sûr au long de la voie il
était président c'était une erreur et
une faute
c'était la part de hollande mais recule
vannes encore un peu sa cuve alti
hollandais ont fait en quoi en faire
quoi
ouais ouais on a pas marre de ta gueule
si mais ça va on se relève anna 4 donc
non mais ils adorent ça
mais évidemment mais c'est le plus gros
vainqueur mais c'est vrai
ouais juste la savoie ouais c'est vrai à
wayne rooney lors il a coûté cher avec
avec bas que j'ai la chance de connaître
c'est que quand il était au summum
qu'aux modes côté dames et sexualité mon
beau frère lui oui c'est que quand il
était vraiment au top il avait aidé mais
bien sûr son très particulier
récemment il avait eu conscience avec
avec sa femme il était au top il avait
dit tout ça là je sais que maintenant on
va où je suis ils vont me le reprendre
donc c'est pour prouver la cruelle
lucidité qu'il est toujours eu sur son
sur son statut sa levée très bien que ça
allait arriver c'est marc van t plein de
fois parce que j'ai la chance de
beaucoup parlé avec lui et moi c'est ce
qui m'a bluffé parce que et au moins ils
me m'a appelé parce qu'un jour quand
j'étais petit commencé à critiquer quel
est votre modèle
à une époque où il était vraiment au
fond pour le groupe des niveaux modèle à
moi c'est bernard tapie le gist toujours
jeu verte cometti bernard tapie qui
n'est pas un métier
voilà une salle encore que mais c'est
vrai que moi ma mère m'a toujours dit
tout mon rêve
elle veut un jour que tu sois bernard
tapie oui mais c'est vrai cette samaâ et
c'est toujours été bien partir je suis e
bernard tapis d'orient vraiment c'est
parmi mes meilleurs souvenirs de
l'interview c'est surtout quand il est
devenu comédien je l'interviewais agents
du [ __ ] c'est vrai que faut
reconnaître que quand vous aime qu'on
vous aime pas vous jouez sacrément bien
maigri mais vous rigolez t'appelles
comment voulez-vous sur mauvais acteur
avant qu'on m'a reproché de jouer la
comédie toute ma vie quand je faisais
mon métier de chef d'entreprise
donc maintenant à fortiori je suis bon
comédien et il s'intéressait énormément
aux jeunes acteurs aujourd'hui prétendre
à l'eau at il ajouté
toujours écrite la décrue des effets
plus de fictions ce moment oui mais bon
dans les fictions il s'intéressait
beaucoup jeunes comédiens ils étaient
désespérés quand les jeunes comédiennes
l'écoutait pas ils commençaient à se
perdre dans des tas de trucs mais ce
commissaire laurence merci en tout cas
vers mars ils nous regardent sache
bernard que je t'aime pas bon et que
maintenant
confiant le maintien jour mon fils il
sera toujours avec moi tu peux être
tranquille je vais pas te lâcher je ne
s'en inquiète wadhah saleh
on